Let's put together some Nature Explorer backpacks for my kids.
So I'm hiding in my dining room right now
because I'm trying to put something together for the kids.
That's a surprise that they're just upstairs,
but I'm putting together little Nature Explorer backpacks for them.
First off, I got these cute little kids size backpacks on Amazon.
Each kid is gonna get a pair of, like,
outdoor gloves,
a set of binoculars, a magnifying glass,
and a couple of these little specimen jars.
That is a fake spider that I came with.
So everything's just gonna go in the little bag.
And this is a perfect gift.
If you have a kid who's super into nature and hiking
and exploring the outdoors,
you can find pre made ones.
But I really wanted to be able to pick the different things
that I put in. Knowing my kids and what they're into,
I thought about also adding in, like,
a little, like,
bird watching guide or an insect guide
or a plant identifying guide
to kind of lead their play in their exploration a little bit, too.
Just an idea. So now my kids are ready for their next outdoor adventure.